boris johnson im kreuzfeuer seine
widersacher versuchen einen geregelten
rexit per gesetz zu verhindern er will
neuwahlen kandidaten schaulauf bei der
spd das rennen um den künftigen
parteivorsitz hat in saarbrücken
begonnen verwüstungen auf den bahamas
hurrikan dorian hinterlässt auf der
inselgruppe schwere schäden und zieht
weiter in richtung usa
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und ein
herzliches willkommen norbert lehmann
ist auch wieder dabei bin schwimme von
mir
wir beginnen wieder mit london denn dort
fliegen im parlament die fetzen der
machtkampf zwischen dem premierminister
und seinen gegnern steuert auf den
nächsten höhepunkt zu nach der
abstimmungsniederlage von boris johnson
gestern kann das parlament heute über
ein gesetz abstimmen das einen
ungeregelten brh exit verhindert es
besagt kommt bis zum 31 oktober kein
vertrag mit der eu zustande wäre johnson
gezwungen brüssel noch einmal um eine
verschiebung des austritts termins zu
bitten
der premierminister aber will den exit
so schnell wie möglich ohne wenn und
aber und schlägt jetzt neuwahlen vor am
15 oktober jahr lang haben sie die
kontrolle verloren premierminister ruft
ein journalist boris johnson heute
mittag zu nun was das parlament betrifft
ist da was dran keine mehrheit mehr und
seine pläne die eu ende oktober notfalls
ohne abkommen zu verlassen von den
abgeordneten unterhöhlt und dazu mit
einem oppositionsführer konfrontiert der
seine attacken einfach abperlen lässt
was sein kapitulation gesetz anrichtet
ist die verhandlungen in brüssel zu
untergraben ansonsten ist nicht klar was
seine strategie ist ich kann wirklich
nicht sehen wie man nicht beschuldigen
kann die verhandlungen zu untergraben
denn es finden ja gar keine statt
dies ist die strategie der opposition
heute die gesetzgebung voranbringen um
ein brett ohne deal zu verhindern
johnson wird daraufhin vermutlich
neuwahlen fordern dazu braucht er
zunächst eine zwei drittel mehrheit die
er aber nicht bekommen wird so lange
dass noten gesetzt nicht hieb- und
stichfest ist und das ist was die
menschen im lande weit weg von
westminster von dem ganzen chaos halten
wie hier in yorkshire
ich weiß einfach nicht aber
wahrscheinlich brauchen wir neuwahlen
die menschen müssen zusammenkommen
sonst erreichen wir gar nicht eine
neuwahl ist reine geldverschwendung und
dann gibt es vielleicht noch ein zweites
referendum noch mehr geldverschwendung
regierung und parlament ringen weiter
erbittert um den dreck sit und das volk
schaut verwundert dabei zu werner
zimmermann in london wären neuwahlen
nicht eine sehr demokratische lösung in
diesem chaos ja natürlich und die werden
auch kommen die oppositionsparteien
allerdings befürchten dass johnston
ihnen eine falle stellen möchten
stimmen sie neuwahlen zu dann kann er
den termin für diese wahlen festlegen
und er möchte natürlich erst wählen
lassen wenn er wie versprochen den exit
geliefert hat mit oder ohne die deswegen
denn die oppositionsparteien vermutlich
heute abend darauf bestehen dass sie
neuwahlen erst zustimmen wird ganz
sicher ist dass großbritannien nicht am
31 oktober ohne die aus der eu heraus
fällt dann also wenn das gesetz über das
eben heute abend abgestimmt wird in
stein gemeißelt ist das wird vermutlich
spätestens montag der fall sein
wir rechnen alle damit dass es dann doch
noch im oktober zu neuwahlen kommen wird
ob die allerdings des rätsels lösung
sind steht natürlich dahin dann ist es
völlig unklar ob es nach diesen wahlen
mehrheiten im parlament gegen oder für
eine bestimmte form von dragset geben
wird die die sache eindeutig klären
dankeschön für diese einschätzung aus
london diana zimmermann
italien hat seine politische krise
erstmal überwunden die neue regierung
steht sie sollen morgen vereidigt werden
ministerpräsident kommt
das gelungen eine koalition aus der
populistischen fünf sterne bewegung und
den sozialdemokraten zustande zu bringen
die städte er heute präsident sergio
materieller vor der chef der fünf sterne
bewegung die mayo soll neuer
außenminister werden
das bundeskabinett hat ein agrar paket
auf den weg gebracht das ziel ein
besserer schutz von nutztieren und
insekten
angesichts des dramatischen insekten
sterben sind strengere regeln für
schutzgebiete geplant der einsatz von
pestiziden soll beschränkt werden wie
schweine gehalten wurden das sollen
kunden künftig schon beim kauf erkennen
können mit dem freiwilligen tierwohl
label es zeigt ob die bedingungen in den
ställen über den gesetzlichen standards
liegen
wilhelm tacke und oliver deuker haben
die details mehr platz licht und luft
landwirt jörn ehlers hält seine 2000
schweine bereits nach höheren standards
als der gesetzgeber vorgibt von einem
staatlichen label das erst einmal nur
für schweinefleisch gelten soll hält er
nicht viel
wir würden uns wünschen dass es ein
verpflichtendes label gibt für alle
verpflichtend und auch mit einer
herkunftskennzeichnung würden wir gut
finden und zielführender finden auch der
koalitionspartner spd fordert ein
verpflichtendes label im alleingang
innerhalb der eu sei das aber nicht
möglich sagt dagegen die cdu ministerin
kann deutschland einen nationalen
alleingang machen ist ja jetzt mal
analog zur eier kennzeichnung die eier
kennzeichnung die verpflichtend ist ist
europaweit geregelt worden ein
nationaler alleingang war nicht möglich
ein weiterer beschluss des kabinetts zum
schutz von insekten soll der einsatz von
pestiziden und 75 prozent reduziert
werden
diese pestizide sind nur noch
erträglichen maße erlaubt und in
ökologisch sensiblen gebieten eben gar
nicht mehr
daher soll auch das umstrittene
unkrautvernichtungsmittel glyphosat ab
geboten werden landwirt jörn ehlers
sieht das kritisch ich würde mir
wünschen dass wir möglichkeiten wo es
keine alternativen derzeit gibt dieses
präparat behalten können aber dann
vielleicht auf einem niedrigen niveau an
menge der bauernverband lehnt die
vorschläge des kabinetts ab
umweltverbände bemängeln dagegen die
maßnahmen seien nicht ausreichend
die spd sucht eine neue führung nach dem
rücktritt von andrea nahles im juni
hatte sich die parteiführung ein langes
auswahlverfahren ausgedacht und das
startet jetzt in die entscheidende runde
17 bewerber haben sich in den letzten
wochen gemeldet heute beginnt ihre
vorstellung bei der basis dazu gleich
mehr
jetzt zeigt axel konrad erstmal werde
alles in den ring steigt
der prominenteste im kandidatenkarussell
es wohl bundesfinanzminister olaf scholz
der vizekanzler tritt mit der eher
unbekannten landespolitikerin klara
geywitz aus potsdam an
bundesweit bekannt das duo gesine schwan
und partei vize ralf stegner
sie kandidierte bereits zwei mal für das
amt der bundespräsidentin beide wollen
die spd nach links rücken
das ost west team petra köpping noch
integrationsministerin in sachsen und
boris pistorius innenminister in
niedersachsen
sie werden mit bodenhaftung und
basisnähe der prominente
gesundheitsexperte karl lauterbach
kandidiert mit der
bundestagsabgeordneten nina scheer aus
schleswig-holstein das linke duo hat die
schwerpunkte soziales und ökologie
saskia esken bundestagsabgeordnete aus
baden württemberg tritt gemeinsam mit
norbert walter borjans an ex nrw
finanzminister der verfechter für
steuergerechtigkeit und die digital
experten haben die unterstützung der
jusos christina kampmann und michael
roth sind das jüngste team unverbraucht
und frisch damit werden sie die
landtagsabgeordnete aus nrw und der
europa staatsminister aus hessen
hilde mattheis aus baden württemberg im
bundestag und der kirche chefökonom bei
der gewerkschaft verdi haben an
eindeutig linkes programm wollen raus
aus der kroko simone lange und alexander
renz
das team von der basis beide
oberbürgermeister
sie erklärten vor wenigen minuten doch
nicht antreten zu wollen und schließlich
noch karl heinz brunner der bayerische
bundestagsabgeordnete tritt allein an
mitglied des konservativen seeheimer
kreises und befürworter der großen
koalition also ein mann und die noch
verbliebenen sieben kandidatenpaare
stellen sich in den kommenden wochen in
23 regionaltreffen der basis vor heute
ging es los in saarbrücken von dort
berichten andreas ruppert und las
bohnsack ein letzter termin für die
journalisten dann gehören die 17
kandidaten den spd-mitgliedern in
saarbrücken
der andrang ist groß nie zuvor wurde die
basis so eingebunden um eine neue
parteispitze zu finden
da sollte es schon sein dass der
parteivorsitzende und jetzt dann auch
die parteivorsitzende geben sich
wirklich mal der partei widmet und die
wieder auf gesunde füße stellt ich
find's gut dass ein öffentlicher prozess
ist und das mit den paaren finde ich ist
ein guter schritt in die richtige
richtung möchte den kandidaten einher
geht auch die frage der programmatischen
ausrichtung der spd
es gilt der partei wieder ein klares
profil zu geben
programmatisch geht es darum die
alltagsfragen der menschen in diesem
land zu beantworten also wie geht es
weiter mit der schule mit der kita wie
kriegt man die straße heile wie es mit
dem mobilfunknetz da muss die spd sich
konkret um kümmern und dann noch die
großen fragen dieser zeit beantworten
klimapolitik verteilungsfragen das ist
das worum die spd sich kümmern muss und
ich bin gespannt ob die kandidaten heute
gute antworten auf diese fragen geben
für die spd ist es ein experiment mit
offenem ausgang und überraschungen
so hat ein paar heute schon seine
kandidatur zurückgezogen
theo koll ist für uns dabei in
saarbrücken
das ist ein ungeheuer aufwendiges
verfahren das viel zeit und kraft bindet
warum tut sich die spd das an nun die
begründung ist dass man natürlich
möglichst vielen parteimitgliedern die
teilnahme ermöglichen möchte denn am
ende sind es natürlich die
parteimitglieder die den oder die neuen
parteivorsitzenden wählen heute
beispielsweise hatte nur mit 300
besuchern mitgliedern gerechnete sind am
ende 6 100 geworden das risiko dieses
langen und aufwändigen prozesses ist
dass die partei sehr als mit sich selbst
beschäftigt erscheinen wird und dass sie
im laufe dieses verfahrens sind
überbietungswettbewerb gerät heute hat
beispielsweise einer der kandidaten
schon an ein investitionsprogramm von
450 milliarden euro gefordert
im raum hier ist auch immer ein großer
weißer elefanten haben das grob also
bleiben oder gehen viele der kandidaten
haben sich dazwischen positioniert am
ende dieses prozesses wird das verfahren
auch über die zukunft der groko in
berlin entscheiden
vielen dank dafür rücken pokal nach
hongkong
es war die hauptforderung der
demonstranten dort das geplante gesetz
für auslieferung an china zu stoppen
jetzt haben sie dieses ziel erreicht
regierungschefin lahm verkündete den
gesetzentwurf zurückzuziehen und
appellierte an die demonstranten und mit
der regierung in dialog zu treten
der demokratiebewegung geht die
entscheidung aber nicht weit genug
in hongkong wird seit monaten
demonstriert für freiheitsrechte und
gegen einen zu großen einfluss giggs
bestürzend sind die bilder die uns heute
von den bahamas erreichen und die zeigen
wie hurricane dorian auf den inseln
gewütet hat mindestens sieben menschen
starben tausende häuser sind zerstört m
at wissen berichtet sie sind mit dem
leben davon gekommen aber die fluten
haben vielen von ihnen alles genommen
meine frau stand auf dem küchenschrank
ist zusammengekracht und da ist sie vor
meinen augen ertrunken
great abaco island aus der luft totale
verwüstung ganze nachbarschaften einfach
ausgelöscht
45 prozent aller häuser zerstört oder
beschädigt 60.000 menschen in not sie
brauchen hilfe dringend aber der
flughafen steht unter wasser die küste
von grand bahama ist kaum noch erkennbar
mit ihren hubschraubern gerettet die
amerikanische küstenwache verletzte der
hurrikan zieht der bei langsam an der us
küste entlang und lädt seine regenmassen
ab dorians kraft hat nachgelassen seine
volle wucht traf nur die bahamas
zum wohl größten steuerskandal in der
deutschen geschichte es geht um die
sogenannten comex geschäfte da hat der
erste strafprozess gegen zwei
aktienhändler begonnen
sie allein sollen den fiskus um hunderte
millionen geprägt haben offenbar nur die
spitze des eisbergs ermittler gehen
insgesamt von hunderten weiteren fällen
aus und von einem schaden von vielen
milliarden zu lasten der steuerzahler
heiko rahms über den ersten prozesstag
sie müssen sich als erste für comics
geschäfte verantworten
zwei britische banker welche rolle sie
spielten versucht seit heute das bonner
landgericht zu klären
den angeklagten wird hier
steuerhinterziehung besonders schweren
fall in 34 fällen vorgeworfen wobei es
einmal beim versuch geblieben sein soll
sie sollen beteiligt dann so genannten
comex geschäften gewesen sein und hier
insgesamt zu einem steuerschaden in höhe
von 440 millionen euro beigetragen hat
namhafte investoren stiegen bei der
suche nach rendite in die sogenannten
comex geschäfte ein
dabei schoben banken und anleger ihre
aktien so trickreich hin und her bis dem
fiskus nicht mehr klar war wem sie
überhaupt gehören folge obwohl die
kapitalertragsteuer nur einmal gezahlt
wurde erstattete das finanzamt sie
mehrfach zwischen 2006 und 11 sollen die
angeklagten bei comex geschäften
mitgemacht haben darüber haben sie
ausführlich bei der staatsanwaltschaft
köln ausgesagt nun gelten sie als
kronzeugen für weitere prozesse gerhard
schick ist finanzmarktexperte er sieht
nicht nur banken in der verantwortung es
gibt auf der einen seite ein richtiges
organisationsversagen im bereich des
finanzministeriums sowohl unter peer
steinbrück als auch unter wolfgang
schäuble die verschiedenen experten
haben nicht zusammengearbeitet und die
finanzaufsicht sagt das hat mit steuern
zu tun das geht uns doch nichts an und
die steuerleute wussten aber nicht was
am finanzmarkt passiert die hätten
zusammen arbeiten müssen und das ist
natürlich die verantwortung des
ministers so etwas zu organisieren
in dem prozess müssen sich auch
geldhäuser als neben beteiligte
verantworten
fraglich ist ob sie für den
steuerschaden der comex geschäfte in
milliarden-höhe aufkommen müssen
schwerer verdacht gegen ex fußball
nationalspieler christoph metzelder die
staatsanwaltschaft hamburg ermittelt
gegen ihn wegen des verdachts der
verbreitung von kinderpornografie
die polizei hatte einen hinweis bekommen
dass eine frau über whatsapp
entsprechendes material von metzelder
erhalten haben soll
der 38 jährige hat sich bisher nicht zu
den vorwürfen geäußert david sauer
berichtet er war an dieser sportschule
zum trainerlehrgang als die
staatsanwaltschaft christoph metzelder
mit dem schwerwiegenden verdacht
konfrontiert
hamburg führt ein ermittlungsverfahren
gegen einen beschuldigten christoph
metzelder wegen des verdachts der
verbreitung kinderpornografischer
schriften
sg um bilder die sexuelle handlungen an
und von kindern zeigen diese soll er
einer frau über whatsapp geschickt haben
noch an der sportschule wurde sein handy
sichergestellt anschließend seine
düsseldorfer wohnung durchsucht
datenträger sichergestellt
metzelder hat mit den ermittlern
kooperiert sich bislang aber weder
gegenüber der staatsanwaltschaft noch
auf anfrage des zdf geäußert
der 38 jährige spielte bei dortmund real
madrid und schalke wurde deutscher
meister dfb-pokalsieger vize-weltmeister
wurde sogar als dfb-präsident gehandelt
er engagiert sich für soziale zwecke
auch für initiativen zum kinderschutz
seit sommer ist mit zell der fußball
experte der ard die lässt die
zusammenarbeit bis zur klärung der
vorwürfe ruhen
christoph metzelder muss aufgrund des
öffentlich gemachten
ermittlungsverfahrens bereits jetzt mit
schweren konsequenzen leben
dabei verbietet sich zum gegenwärtigen
zeitpunkt jede vorverurteilung es gilt
die unschuldsvermutung
zwar gibt es belastbare hinweise aber
auch jede menge offene fragen etwa warum
metzelder diese bilder über whatsapp und
eine freundin versendet haben sollte die
staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt jetzt
weiter wertet die sichergestellten
beweismittel aus ergebnisse sind noch
nicht bekannt jetzt zu einer ikone der
fotografie er hatte eine methode
unvollkommenheit in etwas schönes zu
verwandeln
das sagte model cindy crawford oder über
peter lind bug der berühmte deutsche
fotograf ist im alter von 74 jahren in
paris gestorben
in den 90er jahren prägte er mit seinen
modeaufnahmen das phänomen supermodel
naomi campbell linda evangelista als top
stars nicht bloß als trägerinnen neuer
kleider
zugleich suchte er immer den blick
hinter die fassade und versuchte die das
einzigartige eines menschen zu ergründen
und festzuhalten
[Musik]
zimmer beim fußball norbert übermorgen
wichtige em qualifikationsspiel in
hamburg gegen deutschland hatte ja das
hinspiel in amsterdam mit spektakulärer
mit 3 2 gewonnen das team von joachim
löw hoch motiviert für das duell gegen
den ewigen rivalen
der bundestrainer setzt ganz bewusst auf
guten teamgeist und auf gute laune
joachim löw dürfte zufrieden sein mit
den ersten beiden vorbereitungstagen
gewohnt wird in der neuesten der edlen
herbergen direkt an der außenalster
trainiert mitten auf dem kiez beim fc st
pauli die stimmung im 22er kader ist
nach zuletzt drei siegen voller
zuversicht fröhliche gesichter fast alle
überall
wir freuen uns jetzt hier in einer
kleinstadt in einem geilen stadion auf
zwölf punkte auszubauen wenn es geht und
wir wissen aber auch wie schwer es wird
gegen die holländer vor dem klassiker im
ausverkauften volksbank-stadion ist nur
am rutschen sauer weil ihn sein verein
juventus turin nicht wie champions
league nominiert hat ansonsten ist die
meckerecke neben dem trainingsplatz
lehrern trotz des blamablen scheiterns
der deutschen basketballer in der
wm-vorrunde in china gestern soll
bundestrainer henrik rödl weitermachen
der nationalcoach erhielt vom
präsidenten des deutschen
basketball-verbandes eine jobgarantie
das ziel die verbleibenden drei wm
spiele gewinnen um so die minimal chance
auf die olympia teilnahme zu bewahren
die deutschen volleyballerinnen kämpfen
heute abend gegen polen um den einzug
ins em-halbfinale
nach sechs siegen in serie geht die
mannschaft mit viel selbstvertrauen in
das ko duell in lodz es wird eine
schwierige aufgabe für die junge
deutsche mannschaft wenn 12.000 fans in
der halle die gegnerinnen anfeuern
das glaube ich für keine mannschaft
vielleicht zu bestehen in der atmosphäre
der kulisse es wird gepfiffen beim
aufschlag
das ist schon eine besondere situation
das wird auch für uns glaube ich eine
große herausforderung gegen die starken
polen muss das team seine trümpfe
ausspielen den effektiven
und den stabilen block beides soll heute
abend so hervorragend funktionieren wie
bisher denn die mannschaft will
unbedingt ins em halbfinale die daumen
gib und gehen direkt zum lotto die
gewinnzahlen lauten 27 28 29 34 36 42
und die superzahl 4
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf
seite 55 7
das wetter soll windig und wechselhaft
werden mit dauerregen an den alpen die
details hat gleich gunther tiersch das
heute journal um vor die vor zehn mit
marietta slomka ob morgen begrüßt sie
hier christian sievers und wir wünschen
ihnen noch einen sehr schönen abend auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend liebe zuschauer ab morgen
wird kühl und wechselhaft derzeit
überquert uns eine schwache regenfront
bringt den regen bisschen stärker vor
allen dingen in norddeutschland
ansonsten sind es nur ein paar schwache
regentropfen die da heute nacht hinweg
ziehen aber morgen gibt es hier mit
dieser front dann dauerregen direkt an
den alpen und an der nordsee da ziehen
immer wieder kräftige schauer auf und es
ist deutlich kühler von westen her ja in
den nächsten stunden noch immer schauer
die so langsam hier über norddeutschland
hinweg nach südosten ziehen morgen früh
kann es dann auch im südwesten neue
schauer geben und das sind dann sieben
bis 15 grad tagsüber norddeutschland
richtiges herbstliches wetter also einen
stürmischen wind aus west bis nordwest
immer wieder regenschauer auch mal blitz
und donner zwischendurch die ring
schauer lösen sich aber auch so dass es
nach osten hin freundlich ist mit sonne
und wolken auch in der mitte
deutschlands gilt das so aber dann vom
erzgebirge bis zu den alpen stärker
bewölkt und dauerregen vor allen dingen
vom bodensee bis nach passau wären es
hier im westen am rhein freundlicher
bleibt mit sonne und wolken 15 grad an
den alpen bei dauerregen sonst 16 bis 21
und die wärme steckt noch mal im osten
mit 22 bis 24 grad
es wird kühler in den nächsten tagen
freitag sieht es noch recht freundlich
aus aber am wochenende viele schauer
teilweise eben auch gewitter ich wünsche
ihnen einen schönen abend und machen sie
es gut